hey what's up I'm
Cody I'm
nut and we we're gonna find the real F
boy
today I'm an F boy I'm an F boy I'm an F
boy I'm an F boy I'm an F boy I'm an F
boy give us your name and your best boy
laugh one by one
Lawrence
Marcus
Joseph
L what's your best
one that was wa
[Music]
wait
sin my name is Gabe wait sorry can you
do it again my name is Gabe
that was good was it I thought it was
good I thought it was a little like he
like chuckling there's a difference
between like one time from
you like this is just someone told him a
good joke you know hey man can't hate
the RZ bro if it
works that was right there yeah there we
go how confident are you feeling I feel
confident you know I watch all these all
the time professionally I I think I can
do it I think so I'm going to be honest
I forgot all your names but have you had
sex before yes
for okay have you had sex before
yeah what the [__] dude I don't know I
can't tell I've never seen more of a lie
through your teeth have you had sex
before all the time that's a lot how
often probably bi-weekly matches my
paycheck I have a roster but I max out
at four any more than that is
complicated in a week have you had sex
before yes was it good oh yeah yeah Z is
good to me yeah I would hope so I agree
okay okay I I agree with I agree as well
yeah that's have you had sex before I
don't like to kiss and tell but virgin
that would be like if you had like a boy
script that would be one of the things
that was on it I think I'm very easy to
lie to have you had sex before yeah okay
okay so we have we have actually a
little gift for you we'd love for you to
put these on as soon as you get them in
your hands please this feels Qui at
home okay this was me in high school m
bet can't put it on backwards I'll be
looking good in hats for real the hats
thing was a ploy to see which of them
would put it on backwards or maybe just
wear it like a boy what else what's your
favorite sex position doggy style oh wow
that was quick yeah go wrong with
missionary right missionary okay
squatted cowgir that's like pretty porny
though see I don't know what the name is
but like you have it up and then you
just
the you're not doing like no squ I'm not
Squad he's not squ she's squ it's like a
hood squat you know
yeah you know like I don't know what
it's called but talk there's a mirror
right there and you look in the mirror
you see your thighs it has to be believe
I don't I ain't going to lie I don't
know what the name is I don't know what
the name is does it have to be in front
of a mirror yeah cuz you got to look how
good you look you know what I'm saying
who don't of a mirror I trust him
reverse cow girl for sure okay doggy I
don't
believe everything you say
dude come
on
doggy
doggy I
mean I'm sorry but Gabe is definitely
not the [__] boy oh immediately within
like 10 seconds and I love him I love
him to death oh he's awesome
yeah Gabe Gabe Gabe I love you man I
love me unfortunately the doggy that
that
came
why him out my dog my
[Music]
dog round two fight uh I guess to start
uh go-to pickup line what do you say
what's your move how do you have sex
with that I think depends on the girl
cuz you got to comment something about
her looks or how she's dressed something
different than every other dude goes and
then depending on that go from there no
yeah you know talk to a girl um get her
number take her home to my place you
know I don't I don't believe but a close
second would be my must be Kung Fu cuz
it going Haya no why does it Mak sense
wait sorry Haya yeah what is that H what
does that even mean she's like wait you
know kung fu yeah yeah yeah no but my my
dick you just added go yeah okay uh
Joseph all right for me so let's say
like I'm just going to paint you guys a
picture real quickly let's say we're at
the club right my go-to method is the do
I know you method right so let's say
you're the girl I'm trying to raise up
right I go up to you I'll be like okay
wait wait
oh so I'll go up to you and I'll be like
hey uh do I know you like um I don't
think so no uh did you go to my college
on by Church by any chance back then uh
what college did you go to oh I went to
uh pepperine back back in like a years
ago did you go there by any chance no no
um is your name Tiffany Jasmine or
Michelle by any chance no no h I swear
I've seen you before though anyways my
name is Joseph what's your name Tiffany
Tiffany I I did not want to sleep with
you at all oh if that's your game it
like didn't didn't work very well yeah
you mentioned Church yeah and then I
also also noticed you got the cross
tattoo I'm wondering uh what where does
religion factor in oh it doesn't it
doesn't play any role for me but you you
have the tattoo that seems like a very
strong move yes it was follow it very
well it's just like so you see this
change right it's to remind me that no
matter how far I go into the world I
will be chained by my religion so I'll
still be there you know what I'm saying
so that was too good of an answer that
was really good but that's like a lie if
that's a lie that's a good boy thing
where you lie a lot yeah whatever okay
true are you would you say you are
manipulative no of course not I like
just the way I present myself in the way
I talk I I wouldn't say I have anything
I'm hiding isn't that a thing though to
be like manipulative yeah well I I do
believe
change actually I can manip actually
wait no I am manipulat okay what about
you I don't really have a pickup line
but usually you just act like you know
from you like this
no you
way into it in the club come here okay
to be honest I only approach girls who
look at me so I'll be like hey what's
your name that's it you're giving me
like theater Vibes what does that mean
like you maybe are in plays oh no I
don't know I'm just getting it's like uh
The Stance and like the shoes and belt
and stuff I'm giving it's respectfully I
feel like you're playing a boy in a
music hole yeah
oh damn dude I'm sorry was that really
me
Ian I'm trying to figure I'm trying to
make him CR just trying to picture what
that would be like I don't know I I'm
trying to girls we're going to give you
a hint the real F boy has a relationship
Readiness score of two out of 10 and
their body count is over
50 do with that as you
will what is your exact body count I
stopped at 30 cuz I feel like a better
answer is I don't know how long ago was
that when you stopped a
while okay cuz she's told us it was over
50 mhm well cuz I know for sure I've
slept with more than 20 women since then
30 was a while ago for some reason I
believe him all right but I have my eye
on you it's not something like you
really want to tell a girl that often
yeah but what you were telling us cuz we
asked you tell you guys uh
yeah over 50 over 50 yeah okay what's
your longest
relationship 4 months did you cheat have
you cheated I have not cheated no virgin
the relationship thing was 2 out of 10
which implies like not ready yeah but
you were only relationship I've been in
how long ago was that that was like 6
months ago interesting okay for me 63 to
be exact I I'm like an organized type of
person so I like to keep I like to keep
track of it on like a notepad or I swear
I swear do you have the notepad I I
can't it's confidential it does have
like numbers on it and like my notes on
it and stuff so I notes you're taking
notes on each hookup oh like good like
good eight out of 10 pretty solid no you
don't you're not doing that that would
be like insane if he was yeah once you
do have sex don't do that that would be
why yeah don't do that I'm not going to
lie I kept counting till 50 cuz
obviously all of them not like a 10 you
know some of them you just kind of just
get on you be like uh after you know
like what am I doing with my life so you
just kind of like I don't know it sound
bad bro that's pretty boy sound bad bro
I ain't going to lie but yeah that's why
I don't keep counting after that and you
uh when I turned 25 I honestly stopped
counting how old are you I'm 32 you look
gr for 32 seriously damn must be all the
sex you're having yeah wait why would
you stop at a certain age like I kind of
agree what he said like I get depressed
after I have why would that coincide
with the age you are and not the amount
of people keeping what sorry he said
said he gets depressed after he has sex
I'm like why are you keep why do you
stop doing it so much why are you doing
it sounds like you should sounds like
you should
be I mean I feel
like yeah so let's get rid of them yeah
okay 3 two
1 I wish you sex in the future
yes last round I think we got this the
bag yeah I'm probably just going to nail
it describe your best hookup story um we
were at the club late night 2:30 opened
up a little bit later then we went to an
Afterparty and it was one of those crazy
after parties where people just doing
coke in the bathroom and stuff but I
found a different bathroom and me and
shorty went down there went crazy went
home slept in my own bed never talked to
her again that's like the best of all
worlds this one girl I feel like cuz we
had emotional connection it wasn't like
no wild crazy ass story I think I think
that was love honestly that was like the
best time for me because it didn't feel
like every [__] time we had sex with
another person it felt like real love
and I feel like that's the best one for
me cuz everybody else is do the same
[__] I can't tell if that's a good
answer or a bad
answer true it's it's crazy I don't know
is true that's real but like love I feel
like the best ones is like the love ones
I don't know how long was that a
relationship it wasn't even a
relationship it was a situationship
lines up with the two relationship score
interesting anybody do no relationship
now
all right man what's
you uh so one time me and this girl were
walking home this was in New York and
then we have like a lot of Alleyways MH
and there was a chair in the alleyway
and she's like let me suck your what I'm
like [__] it you got your sucked on a
chair in an Alleyway yeah
why I mean the adrenaline I don't know F
good was there nowhere else like more
comfortable she just really wanted
something about that alley she just like
I really want to suck your right now in
this Alleyway on that show what time of
day was it it was like at midnight oh
okay I was okay I thought midnight
around no no no no no was it near your
house we were we were coming home from
the club so were you like kind of close
to home no I don't take girls home no I
usually go to their
house I don't like to let people know
where I live like I need a Exit Plan
okay
okay what should we do this how does sex
feels
how does sex feel I'll tie your head
just say it I mean amazing sex is always
good sex is good if it's with the right
person like love okay what's with the
love stuff
now I don't know throwing us off now
well it ain't sex if it ain't love I'm
so confused okay how does sex feel saana
is like pretty numb pretty numb s sad
might Swit mess it up I can't okay uh
okay wait uh what does taste like yeah
what does it taste like
acid usually pretty
goodd it depends pH balances bro I had
one girl bro that say she must be
drinking too much sod this is good
though cuz I thought the boy would be
like it's gross I hate it yeah yeah yeah
and you're saying it tastes like acid no
I'm saying some cuz you got different
girls like some tastes good and some
girl love oh her was good I a going to
cap I wouldn't love her if her you know
say I don't eat every girl out you know
what I'm saying you got to get to that
position you feel me you can't eat out
first night after a club that's crazy or
at least shower first cuz I don't want
to be down you know what I'm saying but
after you a couple times then for sure
okay and like salt like salt yeah that
pH balance must be way off this is this
round has completely destroyed what I
thought the answer was going to be I
have no idea now I'm torn I
yeah I think I'm going to redo mine I'm
going to do the same same answer all
right 3 2
1 are you ready to find out your
relationship Readiness score please
download the nectar app on the iOS store
they trap me in this box and they won't
let me out unless I do advertisements
for them if they don't hit a certain
number I'm going to be stuck here please
I haven't eaten in 4 days
I'm trying to text my mom she's not
responding I don't know if I have self
service it's available now on the IOS
app store or click on this link down
below
please uh also Mom I love you if you're
watching
[Music]
this yeah I'm like there are some
questions that I wish I had asked if the
lights turn green you got it right if
the lights turn red you got it got it
wrong all right on the count of three 3
God Warren godam
it godam it I'll watch some of these
videos sometimes I'll be like how do you
not this is so obvious same and then
yeah it's way harder when you're
actually doing it yeah I feel like I
blew
it if it's you I'm going to be soad I
know dude I know giggly yeah the giggly
before if you step forward I'm going to
freak out I will freak out the real F
boy please step forward and share a
little bit about yourself all right here
we go 3
two
one let you walk
out dude if you walked out I would have
freaked out dude I might have left I
might have I might have left at me I was
about I knew it though I knew he he
wrote down he wrote your name down oh
yeah you had it right in the first half
I was worried about that I thought about
that in the moment it's like I don't
mean to be a f boy for real I just love
multiple girls at the same time we're so
dumb we're so dumb he's a I like I'm a
lover you turn your head exactly
probably is that a hickey no no it's
probably it could be though your
relationship Readiness score was a two
two ah that was a shock me too I said
two as a score but I get it though you
know in a relationship you really got to
give 50/50 but also give sometimes 90
and sometimes 70 I don't got that in me
right now over 50 that's unfortunate but
real um going to keep the count going
not
no so who knows you're good with with
your ways and you're oh yeah I'm fine
with you I'll find love one day you know
you sell any courses anytime bro I got
you you you know courses can we can we
ask can we ask why the rest of them are
virgin yes you may okay why are you a
virgin uh I'm young I'm 19 your score
out of 10 was a five yeah I mean that
seems accurate maybe if I meet a girl
I'll Shape Up um I'm I'm I get shy man
it's it's an anxiety so it's not a
religion thing no it's okay interesting
and you scored an eight out of 10 what's
your reaction to that yeah I believe I'm
I'm waiting and searching for the one um
but but so far I haven't found that
person yet you scored out of 10 a nine
yeah I'm not afraid to get into a
relationship and I will give it to my
all I just got to find that one you know
and I want to find somebody who's a
virgin like me I don't want to you know
so we both can be so tired I'm religious
okay I'm very religious so your score
was actually a
three right now my focus is my career
I'm an entrepreneur I do e-commerce Drop
Shipping all that my turn
now here's the thing my upbringing was
so unstable and so chaotic that I didn't
have time to think about anything but
survival feel me cuz I grew up in the
hood I didn't have time to think about
it but now I'm like at a point in my
life where I know what I want and I know
what I'm working for and and I don't
want to compromise that for uh anything
right now any closing words you'd like
to say gentlemen Cody not uh what do you
you have any words uh
doggy let's see
oh
yeah you see it see this what being a a
versin get you you know what I'm saying
it was good with y'all I'mma I'mma head
out y'all be safe though
okay all
right